so now as I progress through you have to
think a little more carefully because
again you can't just put nine here or
six there let's think about that nine
for a minute okay if I know nine people
have eaten lasagna at some point that's
in this circle okay but hold on a second
if I have accounted for these two who
ate neither right how many people are
left to account for in the party there
are 10 people left right so if there's
two people outside the circles there are
10 people inside the circles do you
agree 10 people inside the circles
plural I know 9 of them are in this
circle so how many people are left that
I haven't accounted for yet there's just
think about it I accounted for 2 here
I've got 10 left I can put 9 in here
which leaves just one now they're not
outside the circle circles they're not
in the lasagna circle so where's the
only place they can go there's one there
did you see how I just did that let me
rehearse that thinking again because at
some point right I recognize that in the
both circles right we call this the
Union by the way when you include both
circles together right in the entire
area there there must be 10 left over
the 12 take away the two right but you
know 9 will be in this side which leaves
you only one to be left here does this
make sense you're following ok all right
that was the hard part
the rest of this I think is relatively
easy to do I have accounted for one of
the people who ate apple pie so how many
are left over there are five more people
who read apple pie they can't be here I
just dealt with that part they must be
here in the overlap right I said that
the union Union the union is this whole
pair of circles the Union but that five
that we just mentioned there because
it's where these two sets these two
circles overlap and intersect
we call it the intersection
there are symbols for these in terminal
show you them later okay
there's one last number to put on the
number that I'm actually interested in
how many people are here who only ate
lasagna for and I can check if it all
adds up if I have a look at now I've
covered every region right exhaustively
comprehensively do they add up to the 12
that I wanted thumbs up okay and now
you're ready to answer the question the
probability if you selected one of the
12 at random of selecting someone who a
lasagna only well how many people eat
lasagna only four and if I selected them
out of all of the friends at random its
out of 12 so now I have my answer
just make sense are you happy with that
so you can see this part here right the
numbers and even even these numbers here
they are not complicated but it's the
way you number one thought about how
these relate to each other these sets of
different things and also number two
without me telling you realizing wait a
second this doesn't add up
that must mean there must be things that
have been counted more than once right
that's why there's an overlap that's
what makes Venn diagrams appropriate
just make sense you're happy with that
okay just to finish we were about to
enter XS 10 B you did 10 a right yeah on
Monday okay 10 B so you can open that up
right now if you haven't already but as
you do that you're going to encounter
some weird symbols Cambridge often goes
a little bit off the deep end where it's
explaining stuff they introduce simple
symbols that are main Union both things
and intersection the part that's the
overlap right so the union simple is
really easy it's a a you without a tail
on it are you without a tail on it the
intersection one is very very closely
related
it's a you without a tail but upside
down if you want to remember it this way
I always remember it as you
and intersection that's not really why
it was designed but it's just this
convenient okay you'll see both of these
symbols and we could say for example if
I call this L for lasagna and a for
apple pie that five that five over there
we would say the number of people or
that yet the number of people in the
intersection between lasagna and apple
pie that number what's the number in the
overlap can you tell me it's five right
I could say the number of people in the
union between lasagna and apple pie that
covers everyone who ate at least one of
them right so how many people ate at
least one of them and that's ten right
another way of saying this you're
getting a whole lot of different ways
language and symbols and notation but
they're all getting at the same ideas a
union corresponds to the word or how
many people ate lasagna or apple pie now
this is a distinction you remember
hopefully from Monday but I'm trying to
drug your memory and show you the
parallel here right well ten people ate
lasagna or apple pie one or both what
word corresponds to intersection not or
and how many people ate lasagna and
apple pie at the same moment at the same
time but during the same evening there
are five who ate both are you with me
okay so sometimes you need to be able to
see the symbol sometimes you're looking
for the word and you need to be able to
translate seamlessly between all of them
okay right so by now you're open up to
ten B before I tell you the questions on
there does anyone any questions about
this are you happy with it
this make sense yeah
great question okay so if I go back to
the beginning
oops so let's put this over here and
here if I started back at the start
where I didn't know anything okay I'm
still gonna say and you'll notice this
quickly if you have people who don't
exist in either the sets you're
interested in or three of them or four
however many you've got they're usually
the easiest to put in to but then when
you're constructing the next bit what if
I hadn't thought about this nine what if
I have thought about this six well you
think about it right if I know six are
here six or over here how many people
are in both circles to begin with in
both circles I've got 12 I've just dealt
with two so a 10 to deal with if I know
six are in here how many must be in the
other spot answer for the same for that
you've got before right so the same
logic applies but you have to think
quite carefully about how the numbers
interact and then of course you just
check it at the end to see whether adds
up and makes sense of the information
that you've got make sense